today it's so competitive in the world
that we're in from the internet and the
ability to sell things across state
lines or even other countries right from
a computer like either you got to stay
really small lean and mean or if you're
gonna like you gotta scale fast to keep
up with your competition because others
are doing it what are some of the bad
deals that you see people have made when
they're coming to you what are the most
common terms that they're screwing up on
a lot of times people are scared to
borrow money we've also been programmed
from a young age that debt is bad and
that's bad if you're going to borrow
money and go on a vacation but if you're
gonna borrow money and and take on debt
to build something to invest
um to get a return on that money then
that can be an amazing thing
there he is you what's happening man how
you doing girl by Joe in the house I was
looking up Joe and then realized oh it's
grow by Joe gotta put that little extra
in there I like it dude I like it I like
it I guess your last name was in that
comment right you have been telling
names like what's what's your last name
camberado you know so say that uh you
know a million times fast I guess bro by
Joe is easy to remember than Joe
camberato that's exactly right that's
why I did it was either that or Joe C
which all my friends call me okay Joe C
that could work too I like it cool well
Joe is an expert in helping
entrepreneurs raise money to grow their
business and using some alternative
methods that you may not have heard
about or thought about well let's dive
in man what are some of the
opportunities that you see for
entrepreneurs to raise money that that
they don't see for themselves because
raising money is one of the top
questions I keep getting asked how do I
raise money for my business I said okay
let's ask Joe so what do you got for us
you know I help people Access Capital
so I'm not the money raised guy like
you're looking to start something from
zero but I'm the guy if you started up
your business and you're doing some
revenues you're in business six months a
year two years
um A bank's not an option you know even
even today I mean companies in business
for 10 plus years with great revenues
banks are sometimes still not an option
today which is crazy Banks want to do 20
million 50 million dollar 100 million
dollar plus fundings they don't want to
help the small and you know typical
small business uh owner today so
um my platform National Business capital
I founded in in 2007
basically I created this cool platform
that has really over 75 lenders on it
now so whether you're looking for a line
of credit for a Term Loan
um for equipment financing we just need
straight up working capital you can
apply with me in one place and then
we've got amazing technology which just
speeds up the whole process but we've
got great people here that you can have
a real conversation with and ask
questions and understand what those
options are and then we match you to the
right lender and all that happens really
quickly
um you know we can literally have you
match in hours and funding and hours and
days versus you know weeks and months at
a bank
and you know by following this process
and it's not about getting approved it's
about getting the right approval and
finding the right lender but today that
can be extremely fatiguing and
exhausting you know there's so many
lenders out there today
um so by following this process and
bringing all these lenders into one
place we've secured over two billion
dollars in funding billion guys with a
beat with the big old B and that's over
25
000 transactions now that we've uh dude
that's insane which is crazy it's just
nuts like that's that's amazing I mean I
remember when I first went I mean when I
got my company started I went to a bank
thinking Banks Banks are supposed to
support entrepreneurs right and they
walk in I walked in it's like hey have
you been around for three years like no
like okay can't help you man I was like
okay do you have ridiculous profit you
know do you have collateral if
somebody's at like the early early early
early stages the easiest thing is like
go get some customers and have your
customers help you fund to get started
did or if you're raising an angel round
with friends and family so if you're
kind of like the next step up before
somebody would go to a bank because they
may not have three years historic
financials
what's the criteria what's the minimum
number of of months to be in business
what's a revenue size that's kind of
your sweet spot that you're looking at
for bringing people in
yeah great question and we work with
people like from all ranges right so
um if you're in business for 10 years
doing 20 million in Revenue we work with
those customers but on the very the very
minimum end we need uh six to 12 months
in business
um we're not focused on profit we're
approach we're focused on your existing
sales and what you're looking to use
money for
um so if you've got a like a minimum of
10 to 20 000 a month in sales
um we could start working with you and
get you started on something very small
and then as you grow the difference is
we're not just about the first funding
we'll scale up very quickly so if you're
doing you know 10 grand a month and then
you're crushing it doing 20 then 50 000
a month hundred thousand dollars a month
we can just keep you know um extending
the amount of money that you have access
to very quickly
so helping somebody who's got a
six-figure business get the capital they
need to turn into seven eight nine
figure businesses yep that's exactly
that's exactly and we have customers
that have been with us for 10 years that
have done five to ten fundings with us
and and they just keep growing they keep
reinvesting in their business they buy
other locations they buy more inventory
if they're selling products you know
whatever it is um you know we've we've
had people just scale up with us which
is you know really cool to see you know
um
it's awesome so before I started doing
all this I mean I had my first company
built that sold it and then I spent
about two years as a venture capitalist
uh as an intermediary so I was helping
broker deals for people who wanted to
raise VC funding and we were looking at
like half a million at a minimum up to
15 million for people who wanted to grow
expansion Capital not not startup
um because it raising money becomes a
full-time job
oh yeah yep and then you're not focused
on actually building your business so
it's great to see you know someone like
you now it's not I mean VC I guess could
be an option people are trying to raise
big bucks but also going to different
lenders what are some of the biggest
mistakes that you find entrepreneurs
come in with whether it's their business
planner how they present themselves that
prevent them from getting a deal
um you know I think um I think most
people in general you know they're great
at what they do they're great at you
know their technician piece of whatever
their business is
um they don't really get money they
don't get any of the guidelines
um
um so I think I think you've got to
balance out all these things as you're
growing your business you've got to
understand the financials of your
business
um a lot of people when they first get
started they don't have their financials
together
um they don't really know their numbers
um and and it's understandable they're
just they're in the beginning and
they're getting rocking but you got to
know your numbers you got to understand
your financials
um lenders want like are really focused
especially when it comes to Alternative
lending outside of a bank or focused on
cash flow and seeing that you can manage
money
so sometimes when you're growing you get
your eyes are off the ball and maybe
your account's going negative or
whatever so really managing that cash
flow and doing whatever you can to help
manage that cash flow to help you access
money and you're going to need it when
you're in the beginning you know um I
started the company out of my bedroom
and comp you know back in 07 I
completely underestimated what it was
going to cost you know to get started
um and and you know and also
um thought it was going to happen much
faster so I think it's really important
out of the gate that you understand
these things
um very quickly and if you don't you
know reach out to a company like ours
and just ask these questions and so you
can prepare because you you're gonna
need money at some point in order to
keep growing in the scale fast today and
to stay competitive you just need you
need more Capital you have to keep
reinvesting to get your company up to a
certain point
so when I was doing the VC business I
mean the know your numbers was critical
because people would come in and
obviously it's projections right if
you've only been around for a year
you're trying to make a plan for where
you're going to be in the next five
years and you're trying to show growth
uh but what we would do is look at
you know you have a business plan and
you look at the exact summary and then
after the exact summary we just go right
to the financials and see okay how are
you going to grow and and the I was like
the three main Partners were on their
60s or 70s I've done this for years and
we look at we pick different numbers it
picked different numbers off of the
financial statements year three costs of
goods sold like okay where'd you get
that number from
and if the entrepreneur didn't have a
good answer
then it really shows and they just
picked some random number off of there
it's like okay how did you come to that
and you have yeah it's like oh I don't
know I just thought about it and added
10 and here we are right and so there's
a lot of that where like when you're
going to raise money the financiers they
really care about they care less about
like the vision and mission of what what
could be and care more about like
actually the numbers and are you gonna
be profitable and are they going to get
a return on the investment they're
putting into you
so we would end up coaching them
so that when they go and actually talk
to the VC they would be prepared is that
is that part like are you doing coaching
as well and helping people get a better
handle their numbers or you you need
them to already be prepared coming in
and you can pick a number and say okay
where'd you get that from you better
have a good answer ready for you we wind
up doing a lot of unpaid you know
coaching
um and you know people come to us some
have it together and we just you know
move fast some come to us they're not
ready and we'll absolutely tell them hey
you didn't get approved because of this
this and this do this
um you know for the next 30 60 or 90
days and come back to us we'll be able
to get it done and we fall back up with
them we'll stay in touch with them so
you know it's a combination of all but
we're all about helping we ultimately
listen we don't get paid unless we get
them funding which is really great when
you work with us we're so incentivized
to help you get funding because that's
how you know that's really how we get
paid we don't charge any fees or
anything like that
um up front so
we want to help you and explain to you
you know you know what you need to get
approved and more importantly why you're
not getting improved and I think owners
really appreciate that a lot of times
most companies never give them the why
they're not getting something and I
think if they understand that it helps
them go oh okay I get it and and then
you know now they know what they need to
do for going forward you know I can't
get out of like content mode so this is
such a good show idea for you where you
have entrepreneurs come and Pitch you
and open up their books and like you
tell them what's wrong in a loving way
not like in a in a Gordon Ramsay like
you suck and you'll never make your way
but in a loving way forward yeah to
coach them because nobody's doing that
and there's such a lack of information
and it's so scary you know like people
don't know what their options are the
amount of bad deals that people sign
is ridiculous with lenders where you're
painting like crazy interest rates but
also uh even with Angel Investors like
people would come to us when I was in
the VC business with a great business
but because their cap table was so
messed up because they're they're they
had they brought on Angel Investors
making it kind of non-lingo
um they had Angel Investors take a big
piece of their business like we couldn't
give them the money because they don't
we don't want to spend money no no new
investment wants to come in and give
money to buy out an old investor
yeah
you want to see the money go towards
growing Abyss yeah
yeah so we would get tons of those with
like you
they just made a really bad decision in
the early stages of their business and
now they're almost screwed for any other
capris that they're trying to go after
because they got taken advantage of in
the early stages of their business so uh
I mean I'm sure you've got tons of
stories around that from your livingness
every day we feel and that's what I was
saying before it's not about getting
approved it's about getting the right
approval we'll see people come to us all
the time they went to a not good broker
or applied at the wrong lender and we're
like oh my God if you would have just
came to us we could have gotten you
double the amount of money for half the
cost for like two times longer to repay
it so you would have had a lesser
payment per month you would have got
double the amount of money when you
would have paid back a lot less in
interest and got more money so you know
that that's the whole reason why I
started my platform you know I I prior
to starting the company I just I had
customers that were also self-employed
um I was in the Residential Mortgage
business and I saw how challenging it
was for them to access business funding
and I couldn't understand it so the
reason why I created this place where
all brought all these lenders together
so I felt like you know owners shouldn't
be able to you know should not be
restricted in growing their business due
to lack of capital the lack of the right
capital
um and started helping One customer at a
time and they'd get turned down from
their bank and then I'd find them the
right lender and watch their businesses
grow
um you know so it's really important to
find that right lender and and but not
to get burnt out doing it you know
that's why we created the platform is is
it fair to say that you're basically a
mortgage broker for entrepreneurs trying
to raise money for their companies yeah
we're like so we're like a rocket
mortgage meets max.com right and and uh
I think that's a great do you like that
analogy I like it you know why you know
I like that because you think even how I
position at you wasn't is great because
for the mortgage you don't really care
what bank you're going to as long as
you're getting a good deal but you don't
want in a business you don't want to
bring in the wrong lender or investment
into your company yep yeah so I like the
match.com bonus to it yeah it's very
little bonus it's an added bonus so
we're we're just matching the the right
borrower to the right lender yeah and
we're doing that very very uh very
quickly I love that like if you thought
about a grow by Joe show
it's funny Steve and I have been talking
about something so stay tuned on that
we've got actually uh something that
we're working on that we'll be sharing
you know hopefully uh hopefully pretty
soon that should be pretty interesting a
lot of fun
even just coaching entrepreneurs having
to come in to show you their their
financials and you do a seven minute
thing with them and then break it down
and you spend half an hour with them and
maybe it ends up getting a deal from
that person or maybe it's just education
for other people but if people can see
because you actually care you know like
it's there's a lot of guys in the
finance business it's just okay deal
you're just a number next but you
actually care about helping people want
to grow and so seeing that heart is
really rare in in financial services
um so like if somebody comes on and
pitches them pitches like that's what I
if I was still not going to be sea days
that that would be my I'd have a Daily
Show I actually love the idea I think uh
you got my wheel spinning out so
maybe submit their financials and then
you say what's wrong what's great what
to fix and here's how you can get a deal
and it'll lead to
it'll lead to people caring and people
want to work with you because they love
like I had we had a guy make a deal with
us just because one of the founders at
the VC firm on his bio put that he
worked at a charity like he was on the
board of a charity
yeah and when you're at the high level
in BC these companies can go anywhere
right it's like why would I go with you
versus somebody else they have options
because they have a great business right
so they work with us just because one of
the
founders
was on the board of advisory at a
charity because nobody else actually
didn't need community service inside the
VC world and so having a show like that
will make people say oh my God like this
guy Joe actually cares
I want to go with him
that's cool no I love that and uh it
could be a lot of fun and it's like
you're killing a few you know birds with
one stone there too just like a learning
piece of it where others could uh you
know learn and uh that could be a lot of
fun I like it thank you do you want to
do it let me know I know a guy who knows
something about YouTube
I'm gonna help then
um I appreciate that good stuff so like
I think a lot of entrepreneurs are just
afraid of money they don't understand it
as much especially the more Visionary
entrepreneurs is it a case where
once when when you say know your numbers
uh is it that the entrepreneur needs to
be doing a lot more research should they
be bringing somebody on their team
should they be having their CPA on their
Advisory Board being a part of it
somebody who like really struggles with
that what's their solution well you you
know I think um
when I say know your numbers you know
you got to really understand like what's
happening in your business just
understanding what's going on you also a
lot of people I I always tell especially
people in the beginning as they're
getting going like
where like where are you getting the
best bang for your buck like where is
your where are you making the most
amount of money because a lot of times
you're doing a number of things and
you'll do things that maybe you love
doing or just gravitate towards because
you're comfortable with it or you just
got all the stuff going on you don't
even really know what is like what's
what's driving you know 50 of your
profit or 80 of your profit and
sometimes as entrepreneurs you'll get
caught up in these I call them squirrels
and you'll run in different directions
but like where is the real money coming
from and once you identify that
you know what's the profit margins
around that a lot of times people are
scared to borrow money
because like oh my God I'm going to have
a payment I'm going to have to pay
interest we've also been programmed you
know from a young age that debt is bad
and that's bad if you're going to borrow
money and go on a vacation I don't I
don't really agree with that
um in this new Millennial era but if
you're gonna borrow money and and take
on debt to build something to invest
um to get a return on that money then
that can be an amazing thing and it's a
lot cheaper than Equity so
you know when I say no your numbers like
know where you're making a profit note
that if you borrow money and you've got
to pay you know 8 10 12 15 interest
um that you know if you're if you've got
a return on your capital of you know 20
30 40 50 60
um from whatever you're doing your
business like know those numbers and
it'll make it really clear that wow if I
borrow this and do this I can bring in
that much more money per month which
would cover the payment plus I'd profit
this and a lot of times people just
don't necessarily know that math
or they do know that they've they you
know they know they need to borrow money
to get to that next level but they don't
really know exactly what they're going
to make from it so it almost feels more
daunting when they go through the
process and then we have these
conversations with them and help break
it down and a lot of times when we break
it down
um with them they're almost like you
know surprise and take it back and then
they're like oh like a lot more
comfortable with the decisions that
they're making and almost gives them a
lot more confidence in the decision that
they're making so you know I think
listen when you get started your
business a lot of things are gut and
feel and and that's probably what makes
some of the most you know probably some
of the most successful entrepreneurs by
having a really good gut instincts but
you got to put some pen to paper and get
clear with your numbers and understand
it
um then you can take those gut instincts
with some real facts and and be really
way more confident in the decisions that
you're making and confident to borrow
money
um and you know we say this all the time
Evan a lot of times
it'll actually cost you more money to
not borrow money like if you've got an
opportunity to grow your business
there's a real Roi like you can do
nothing and stay you know where you're
at or if you borrow money you know it
can bring your your company this level
so it costs you more to to not borrow
and take on that risk
yeah especially expansion Capital which
I guess is where you know you're focused
mostly on right so yeah for not
entrepreneurs like again when we're
looking at raising money there's the r d
phase at the very beginning where you
don't even know if you've got something
that might be something like you don't
go to A lender asking for money on that
because then you're putting up your
house or some personal asset to make
that happen that's if you need money
that that's like government grants and
programs and then there's a startup to
make sure that it's like actually like
let me get my first customers but then
there's the there's the expansion in in
the growth phase and you may be missing
out on huge opportunities by not going
faster because there's somebody else out
there who's doing it uh and expansion
capital is the easiest money to raise so
to your point about opportunity like you
could have if you're at a six figure
business you know you cross 100 000 a
year cool next year you're at 200 000
but maybe you should be at 2 million
because you're able to take out some
money and grow
um do you you only focus on that correct
or are you also doing equity no my main
focus is debt I mean every once in a
while we'll come across something unique
and I'll share some stuff on my network
for uh you know on the equity side but
the company's main focus is is that
and what are people looking at in terms
of rates right now
kind of ballpark or criteria what are
what are the ranges that somebody's
looking at if they're trying to bring on
some debt equity yeah
debt Equity yeah yeah no I get it and uh
and just to respond back to what you
just said too about going from 200 000
to 2 million and growing fast like I
think today it's so competitive in the
world that we're in and you know with
the from the internet the ability to
sell things across state lines or even
other countries right from a computer
like either you got to stay really small
lean and mean or if you're gonna like
you gotta scale fast to keep up with
your competition because others are
doing it
um and it's it's competitive in all
Industries out there
um but to answer your question on on the
the debt numbers so basically if you're
going to do um like a bank a SBA type of
deal
um you're gonna look at like prime plus
two to three percent
um so right now that'll put you between
like six and a half and seven to eight
percent
um if you are um gonna Finance equipment
you're looking at anywhere from five to
eight to ten percent
um depending on uh Credit in a number of
different things
um if you're looking for
um something that's secured by assets
assets can be B2B receivables
um real estate
um or heavy machinery
um you're at like prime plus two to
three percent
um and then if it's you know just purely
on cash flow you're looking at like 9 10
12
um and then rates like in the mid teens
um and then if it's if there's a lot of
risk could even get higher than you know
than that
and then so what are some of the bad
deals that you see people have made when
they're coming to you and like oh I
signed this deal what are they paying or
what are the most common terms that
they're screwing up on
you know I'll see people work with a not
good merchant cash advance lender and
take a really short-term deal four to
six months to repay it very high rates
20 30 percent
um and where they were in a you know
needed something fast and
um you know and they just were at a
lender that didn't have all the options
you know what makes us so good at what
we do is we've got over 75 lenders so we
can work with prime credit down to not
good credit and all those will be
different lenders that will work with
um and and even if you don't have great
credit if you've got good cash flow
you've got an opportunity we can look
past that and still give you you know a
really great deal
um and sometimes we see these deals that
come to us and they're really it's not
like they were just in a situation where
they were you know gonna they were
supposed to get paid they've got the
money coming in they the receivables you
know you know didn't get paid when
they're supposed to by one of their
customers and they're in the middle of
another project so they just laid out a
ton of money expecting money to come in
and they've got a one payroll on Friday
um and they had to take a fast deal to
plug a hole and you know maybe have the
time
um
to look around but if they would have
just came to us we could have given them
that same deal
um probably more money
um you know two to three times the
amount of time to repay it
um and uh and and a realistic interest
rate you know so you know we see those
situations all the time and sometimes
people just don't know you know they're
not even in that situation they they've
shopped around at a bank in a bank in a
bank and they get to you know you know a
broker that just doesn't have all the
options uh like we do we've got 15 years
of relationships and they just get
fatigued they we call lender fatigue you
know I mean you're in your business you
apply one lender then another lender
then a third lender and you've got to
fill out an application again that are
lengthy or ours is a one-pager some of
these banks are like five pages in a
story
it's exhausting I mean who's got the
time to do that you're still running
your company you know so
um you know so we see that lender
fatigue will get you know well people
will kind of just push people to take
something because they're just they're
sick of dealing with it people don't
know that's why the watch the grow by
Joe show let's go
care and like how much you are trying to
point an education and helping people uh
people want to dive in your world learn
more contact you like where's the best
place for them to go
yeah if you want to follow me uh follow
me at grow by Joe
um on YouTube on LinkedIn on Instagram
and uh if you want to explore more speak
with my team uh learn your you know you
know see what uh fundings uh options you
can get qualified for you can go to
nationalbusinesscapital.com that's
nationalbusinesscapital.com
amazing thanks for the love man I'll
talk to you soon all right back at you
thank you Joe do you see my one-on-one
with Grant Cardone check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe I'll see you there
true wealth cannot be created working it
could only be created and best Elon Musk
is completely invest
he has no cash and no houses